hello and welcome to this video playing
chess commando was there was the guy
with the kings and you know just some
games ago okay
now that's interesting line but should
be to what do I do that 95 right you
know 25
okay Wow and it's not very ambitious so
how do we do that with the porn up sorry
with the pawn up with the tempo up I'm
going for long castling and I really
don't see why I shouldn't do that here
as well like with wider colors reversed
with white long castling is a good idea
then G 4-h form yeah here he s he is a
tempo up compared to that s he's white
but yeah for white in the scotch four
nights a night takes d4 and song is
really really comfortable okay so he
decided to to weaken the central
structure there enormously yeah now this
is actually an interesting an
interesting decision if you want to
Castle queenside it is actually quite
tempting to simply play now for the
weaknesses and I'm going to do that okay
it's not threatening here anything here
right
no before awesome
the moment I'm castling non-threatening
night deform winning that even works
after d4 Knight takes d4 because I have
the intermediate mathematics it would
check always like 94 2792 check ok I'm
checking
so now 94 is a huge threat it wouldn't
be entirely surprising if he plays King
edge 1 now if he understands the threat
very very likely he does anything he
takes a moment damn probably trying to
figure out ok that is possible I mean
just covering the Queen it is a very
awkward looking moonstone ok yeah even
just night before comes into
consideration but it would be nice to
Queen s has no squares
[Music]
I'm wondering if I can play something
like um move the Queen and then Bishop
to d7 threatening threatening the
discoveries it's not sure about it it's
a bit of a tactical approach which is
kind of yeah it may be good but I was
just better by a normal means so I'm
always a little bit cautious with
technical solutions when I'm just better
by playing playing standard moves this
might be very good though Knight 94 is a
huge threat and I don't quite see what
he's doing against that so it might just
work but I wasn't entirely sure because
I could basically play whatever and just
have a huge strategic advantage yeah
he's got no squares so just no squares
Queen B 594 25 check Bishop e6 wins wins
on the spot if he takes again 94 so the
best he can do is probably get to two
minor pieces for the Queen maybe that
was a good tactical approach don't know
again I'm always a little bit skeptical
because in particular in situation where
just normal moves are a clear advantage
okay so he covers everything not
everything but he can he covers kind of
stuff so an idea for Queen takes a 7 is
the idea okay
okay let's take if I could knight c6
just back he has to go to a four again
again going into that discovered
discovered attack night before and
somehow it doesn't win yeah it's kind of
kind of weird anyway I mean this is good
let's play it
didn't expect this one of course nine
ticks it's probably not even that bad
just I did not think about to move it on
[Music]
always frustrating stuff like that works
okay so my bishop should be a lot
stronger than the bishop queen g5 f3 f3
as a as a problem for him
okay just stroke chicks I hope takes us
a queen trait then that's not great yeah
let's just go neither near the king
I don't want to trade Queens absolutely
not
how do I get the rook get the rookie
into the game here I don't see a way to
get the rook activated shoot King create
actually I know it's a bit of a
back-and-forth but it's not much time
and now I think I'm getting somewhere
tough defense
you managed to trade rooks don't believe
it
I can take it
I only have six seconds so I have to be
a bit cautious here with everything
I shouldn't trade Queens technically
speaking but my King position is just
much better but I think it should be
reasonably simple
no Bishop is stopping the corn okay
so yeah that was so tough they defended
this quite tenacious room yes it
interesting interesting part IAM of the
game some Queen d7 Bishop III you can
castle on Queen Santi definitely it's
not that this is bad I can still play
like this and claim that yeah this is
very weak but White has this at the end
I wasn't totally shown angel likes black
initially at least but and this is this
is this is not bad da I think so
Queen a form there should be several
hook to you one
Castle its non-threatening night to
deform yeah let's say if you play
something stupid
this one yeah 94 this is the problem
because I have this engine media check
this is the idea the same problem is
with d4 I can still take and win the
house so b3 was designed to cover this
and the engine wants to go queenie 8 and
then Bishop d7 yeah maybe this is the
better way to do it but this is also
giving me a pretty big advantage so I'm
missing a win here efore is winning why
why is said winning so this this and
then I then I'm taking and okay okay
okay okay no I know I get it
so this and they have Bishop g4 right
yes
that is very good no didn't see it
before is better
let's bet him I mean this shouldn't be
terrible and it isn't but knight c6 and
then if or is the same idea I am I
didn't see if or Bishop g4 it was just a
blind spot I didn't see it at all okay
so my dear queen g4 was winning ah okay
you know what I didn't see
I have Bishop takes or even Bishop takes
f3 winning
this one's I missed so many wins down so
this is just all them yeah one thing is
this is Queenie one Roger and and also
Ruka eight of course I'm also
threatening to win the Queen oh shoot
just winning the quick cut so I missed
millions millions of things Queen d7
wins okay that doesn't win okay so I
made the ton of mistakes really a ton of
mistakes and here black is back in what
white is back in the game yeah Jim I
wanted to take with the rook but a
bishop takes us is already winning one
Queen f6 yeah white shouldn't survive
this King position I really took ages to
get somewhere five probably there are
some things for both sides we both had
like 10 seconds and the only thing that
I was trying is to never trade Queens
and keep keep everything on the board
here h5 is winning yeah yeah you have to
be realistic there how Bishop f3 was
simply I'm that that I should have seen
okay and the way it turned out I was
somehow winning the b3 corn Jim didn't
want to trade books but so I am going to
pawn somehow maybe there was a mouse
slipper the end here this is again
fairly fairly simple win yeah that was
was tough and I missed many many many
long many wins here in fact ninety xt5
is a bit odd what usually cast
and this is actually leading to two
interesting play something like this
where white can try for f3 this is a
playable variation for why nothing ok
guys thanks for watching